in the 1930s australian farmers had a
really big problem their sugarcane crops
were being decimated by a voracious grub
the larvae of the cane beetle which
destroys the plant's roots
after failed attempts at chemically
controlling the grubs officials sought a
biological solution they thought if they
introduced a predator of the beetle the
grub problem would go away
at the time the thought process wasn't
entirely unreasonable but it would turn
out to be the single worst decision they
could have made after hearing about a
measure to control a similar cane beetle
in hawaii with the voracious cane toad
australian officials jumped at the idea
after dutifully carrying out exactly
zero studies of the potential impact on
the australian environment they
transported a hundred toads from hawaii
and let them loose and with that single
action the australian ecosystem was
never the same one hundred toads quickly
became one thousand and then ten
thousand and then ten million and then a
hundred million they have rapidly spread
over much of the continent
today cane toads properly known as bufo
marinus or buffo toads are the most
notorious of all invasive species in
australia this lumpy guy is massive
poisonous and seemingly unstoppable the
biggest cane toad ever recorded was
almost 40 centimeters or 15 inches long
and weighed 6 pounds or 2.75 kilograms
it eats anything it can fit into its
mouth
insects trash dog food small reptiles
small rodents and even birds
the one thing it doesn't eat though is
the cane beetle cane beetles perch too
high off the ground for cane toads to
reach and the toads certainly can't get
to the grubs underground
so you could say there are some regrets
cane toads are now moving westward at a
remarkably fast pace and the australian
government admits that it's unlikely
that they will ever be fully contained
since their introduction 87 years ago
cane toads have been linked to the
decline of several native species in the
northern territory in queensland
including the australian monitor lizard
the northern blue tongued lizard the
australian water dragon the king brown
snake the common death adder and the
northern coal many species are at risk
of total extinction all because of this
stupid ugly toad what is it about the
cane toad's particular biology that
makes it so destructive and able to
spread so easily why are some introduced
species worse than others and what can
be done to stop them
invasive species unfortunately have
become a major part of our modern world
they can be introduced to an area by
ship ballast water accidental release or
like in the case of the cane toad by
misguided intentional human action
but a common misconception is that any
species found living in its non-native
habitat is an invasive species
this however is not the case many
species are introduced to new areas
without it being a problem most crops
for example are non-native potatoes for
example are from south america but are
now grown on most continents without
causing an issue honeybees were
introduced to the americas from europe
in the 1600s and have yet to cause any
major problem a species only gets the
invasive title when it causes harm to
the environment displaces or
out-competes native species hurts the
economy of the area or becomes a danger
to human animal or plant health
the brown tree snake has eaten a dozen
kinds of forest birds in guam to
extinction
zebra mussels clog pipes around the
great lakes and speaking from personal
experience shred your feet to a pulp in
lake travis
house cats murder any creature they can
get their paws on if they're let outside
pushing as many as 70 bird reptile and
small mammal species out of existence
already the kudzu plant is a climbing
vine that smothers and out competes
native plants all over the southeastern
united states and grows up to a foot a
day
all of these organisms have found a
place to thrive where they didn't
originally evolve meaning other
organisms haven't had the time to adapt
to their presence
native organisms don't have defenses
against the invaders methods to compete
alongside them or even ways to prey on
them and the cane toad's particular
biology makes it so most of the natural
inhabitants of the australian ecosystem
don't stand a chance
largely because cane toads are extremely
poisonous
adult cane toads have venom secreting
poison glands on each shoulder where a
highly toxic milky substance is released
when they are threatened if an animal
tries to bite at the toad the venom is
secreted directly into the animal's
mouth and its effect is almost instant
the venom which is full of cardiac
glycosides causes sodium to build up
within the animal cells when this
happens in heart cells it completely
alters the rhythm of the heart usually
making it beat out of control
meanwhile potassium builds up between
the cells which can cause paralysis
this then leads to difficulty breathing
convulsions and soon after death
a cane toad's poison can kill within
minutes
this makes the cane toad quite an
undesirable snack for most animals
especially animals in australia in the
cane toad's natural habitat of south and
central america some predators like the
broad-snouted caiman have evolved
mechanisms to block the action of the
poison but similar predators in
australia have not had time to keep up
their end of the evolutionary arms race
freshwater crocodiles in australia are
experiencing mass die-offs due to the
very same toad
a study conducted in 2008 saw 77
of freshwater crocodiles die in a period
of three years directly following the
inland progression of cane toads from
the mouth of the victoria river
the pace of their deaths exactly matched
the pace of the toad's invasion but all
hope is not lost for the crocodiles
eventually the high death rate may
naturally select for crocodiles that
have a higher tolerance to the toad
toxin
this is already being observed in some
black snake populations that have been
hit hard by the cane toads
and other animals are adapting too in
even freakier ways
australian water rats have learned to
flip cane toads over to carve out and
eat their hearts with surgical precision
avoiding any toxins
in turn this could have a positive
effect for other native animals
with enough time maybe there is hope
that australian animals can fight back
but unfortunately it's not just the
adult cane toads that are the problem
even the eggs and the tadpoles are
poisonous which if ingested by
vertebrate predators like fish and
turtles can be fatal
and this is no small threat
cane toads don't just lay a few eggs
they lay an apocalyptic amount of eggs
and their toxicity added to their sheer
numbers is creating a completely
unexpected evolutionary event
the life of a cane toad begins within an
egg one cane-toed female can lay up to
forty thousand eggs at a time that's a
lot of eggs but usually when an animal
has so many offspring they don't expect
many of them to survive
but the problem with the cane toads in
australia is that basically all of them
do survive
these tiny black dots speckled down the
string of eggs soon will hatch into
tadpoles and the pond in which they live
will become full to the brim completely
blackened with them killing most
predators that try to eat them
these tadpoles gradually develop
forelimbs and hind limbs reabsorb their
tails while their gills disappear and
their lungs develop
once metamorphosis is complete armies
emerge onto land as young toads and
these armies are only getting more
formidable between the 1940s and 1960s
cane toads expanded their range by about
10 kilometers per year but today cane
toads are moving west at a rate of 50
kilometers a year
why are they so much faster now than
before
at first researchers thought that the
toads might somehow be slipping onto
trucks and hitchhiking across the
country to find out for sure they
strapped tiny radio transmitters onto
the toads and what they found shocked
them the toads were not hitchhiking but
were themselves traveling at an alarming
rate up to 1.8 kilometers a night
far further than any other frog or toad
ever studied
could this ever accelerating takeover be
a result of the army of toads evolving
into a faster toad right in front of our
eyes
while researchers can't go back in time
to race modern toads with the first
toads brought over from hawaii what they
can do is look at preserved specimens of
toads from decades ago and what they
found is that over a 60-year period
australian cane-toad's legs have grown
over 25 percent
and scientists soon realized that the
modern cane toads with the largest legs
are those on the western front the first
toads to arrive in a new area
later waves of toads have shorter legs
the cane toads that are able to spread
farther and faster have much less
competition and thus there is an
adaptive advantage in doing so the cane
toads were always spreading fast but now
they are evolving to spread even faster
this is all pretty worrying
where we used to think vertebrates can't
really evolve on such short time scales
the cane toad is proving that they
absolutely can if the conditions are
right and for invading organisms whose
populations explode very quickly this
rapid evolution is all the more likely
and all the more dangerous
but the intense competition between the
toads that's driving adaptation has an
upside
the toads are quickly evolving a taste
for themselves they've become so
numerous that their only natural
predator is other cane toads
and while scientists have observed
cannibalism evolving in animals before
they've never seen it evolve so quickly
adult cane toads can be seen eating
smaller toads but it's their tadpoles
that are doing most of the cannibalizing
researchers found that a handful of more
developed tadpoles can devour 99
of the tiny hatchlings that emerge from
the tens of thousands of eggs in a
single clutch
so in this instance their immense
numbers and rapid evolution is helping
to put a cap on their numbers
but short of the cane toads eating each
other out of existence is there anything
we can do to stop them
australians understandably want the cane
toads gone but unfortunately there's no
great way to round them up and kill them
the government community groups and
frustrated individuals do their best to
cull them but it's not easy and not
always humane
the best thing is to get rid of them get
a big stick and hit a method the current
guidelines on the most humane way to
kill cane toads is to stick them in the
freezer
some groups try to trap large numbers of
toads using speakers to play the cane
toad's song to lure toads to it other
people just straight up shoot them with
air rifles hit them with golf clubs or
run them over in their cars when i'm
driving a car i have no hesitation of
running over them whatsoever there are
even toad busting militias that make it
their mission to kill as many of the
toads as possible but there are too many
toads in australia to eradicate by
simply removing individuals that's why
some want to take a more intentional
approach researchers are trying to
genetically develop a cane toad that can
only produce male offspring using
something called a w shredder gene drive
[Music]
the zw sex determination system is a
chromosomal system that determines the
sex of offspring of animals like birds
some fish some reptiles and the cane
toad a z and a w chromosome will give
you a female and double z chromosomes
will give you a male this is sort of the
opposite of the mammal system where the
heterozygous xy gives you a male and the
homozygous xx a female and in the zw
system it's the egg that determines the
sex of the offspring unlike the xy
system where it's the sperm a w shredder
toad is a toad who's been gene edited so
that all of its w bearing eggs are
defective that leaves just z-bearing
eggs so when the male adds his
z-chromosome to that you get only z-z
offspring meaning you get only male
offspring and if the w-shredding gene is
located on the z chromosome then this
shredding gene can be inherited with
enough gene shredder toads in the
environment the number of females will
be greatly reduced and a male dominated
population would be incapable of
effective procreation
some may argue against this technology
saying we have clearly already messed
with nature enough but at this point
when the damage has already been done
and the toads march on we don't have the
luxury to not intervene
we as a species already are playing god
whether we like it or not
so we might as well get good at it we
might as well do it in a well researched
calculated way to undo some of the
damage we have done
but despite their destruction we can be
grateful for the cane toads for one
single reason they are the subject of
the single greatest cinematic experience
a person could ever have
this whole video was inspired by a
memory cemented in my brain from 10th
grade biology of watching the most
hilarious documentary i have ever seen
perhaps you too have a distant memory of
a cane toad named dairy queen
inexplicable camera angles amazing
interviews grown men singing songs in
the shower about cane toads while they
stalk him psycho style
all textured with 80s synth and
incredible jingles
[Music]
it feels like a mockumentary but it's
all real like a love child of national
geographic and monty python the cane
toad problem is obviously an awful thing
but sometimes in the face of a terrible
situation all you can do is laugh and in
all seriousness it's a powerful piece of
science communication
this film's been cemented in my brain
for 15 years after all
as i was trying to reminisce on this
magical film i wondered if i would even
be able to track it down and to my great
surprise and delight i realized it's on
curiosity stream in its entirety i
almost could not believe my luck if you
haven't seen it go watch it now you will
not regret it and if you're like me and
watched it years ago go re-watch it i
promise it's just as funny now as it was
back then
and make sure to watch it on
curiositystream to support this channel
and other independent creators like me
curiositystream is a great platform in
itself with incredible documentaries but
it also supports us to keep making
videos like this for you and because
curiositystream has partnered with us
you can get in on an incredible deal by
signing up to curiositystream you now
also get a subscription to nebula
is a streaming platform made by me and
several other educational youtube
content creators it's a place where we
can upload our videos ad free and a
place where we can experiment with new
original content without worrying about
the youtube algorithm by signing up to
the bundle deal you'll get access to
both curiosity stream and nebula where
you can access our upcoming original
series like real engineering's battle of
britain series or my upcoming original
series about human evolution there are
so many original exclusive documentaries
on nebula from some of youtube's very
best creators like wendover productions
tierzoo or joe scott so by signing up at
curiositystream.com
real science you'll get a subscription
to curiosity stream and a subscription
to nebula for just 14.79 for the entire
year
signing up is also the best way to
support this channel and all of your
other favorite educational content
creators and if you're looking for
something else to watch right now you
can watch our previous video the insane
biology of venus fly traps or watch real
engineering's latest video the truth
about carbon taxes which in brian's
words discusses future scenarios of how
to eat coal from the electric grid
you